khoảng 2,5 mỡi kí lưu gàm. Khám sách nhà của các đổi tượng, thu dưới nhiều đồ bật tại liệu
có linh quan đến phạt động phạm tội, nhiều các bộ kích liệm, khoảng lòng,
con một kí lưu gàm ớt bộ, muốn sì máy các loại. Đây là nhóm đổi tượng
hạt động có tuổi trước, phân công phai tròn rất trạm chẽ, tuổi bản tin vi,
người an ngược lớn đến anigrateg và đời sống nhận dân. Chứ tình như đó,
cưu quan tong an đã rất lập truyến an, tập trung lực lượng,
ác sợc đồng bộ các biệt phát nghiệp của để đấu chăng chị só á, theo tại liệu đều tra,
gióng đổi tượng sò khoảng văn phàn, sinh năm 1910,
chữ tại phường thống nhắc định giải lại cẩn đầu. Hẳng ngày 12, đến thứ 6,
các đổi tượng chân mình báo, sinh năm 1910, phạm mình phúc, sinh năm 1910,
con chú tại phường, tệ cù, xa ai, và người an phần đất, sinh năm 1910,
chữ tại phường sinh hồng gia ai, điều kiện xe máy tập kết tại nhà hoặc văn phàn,
ở số năm 1910, phường thống nhắc vào khoảng 2018. Sau đó,
các đổi tượng thay đổi trang phục phương tệ, miệng số xe,
tảng ra đi chủ tró át thêm tình cập trên hai chiếc xe máy.
Để nhăng trống bắt tró, các đổi tượng xử rộn tích liện thong lọc,
thậm chí là mang theo ớt bộn định trống trả nếu bị phát hiện.
Mối đềm các đổi tượng đi bắt tró,
mang về liền tập bết từ ba liên xấu lực,
vào thời gian từ 204, đến sạm sáng. Tập kết hàng,
vui 204 lệ đại hàng phần tượng nhắn,
phần lớn, hàng được bắn cho ch JEN tân qua sinh năm 1910,
quế giảm viên xe yên leader,
t额 kinh, chịu tại giả nát gương qua, để quản áe.
Ngoài ra các đổi tượng còn bắn cho một tủ khoảng tịt kài trên địa vμα các
phường lệ CЫN HUB FOR DURRU.
Theo đổi trả, ko khoảng 4 bệ giơ hằng này,
tòa, điều kiện xe máy kéo thiêu lớm moch, đến nhà số 21 lệ đại hàng
trở hàng cho nên sau đó vẫn chuyện Pề nước ở để cóng lại
Tương một cái hành này rồi nươi đi tư thủ tại các tính khác thông qua sẽ khác hoặc sẽ tài
Nó khách năng hành in phương trời thay là đến nay, uống tính các lưỡi tượng đã mắt trộng khoảng 5.2 trong cơ tró,
tổng trộn lượng 5.2 tấn, tù lợi bắt chính khoảng 2 phẩy sấu tỷ đồng.
Sau khi truyến án đựng phá thị cơ, nhiều người dân đã đến cơ quan cầu ăn để nhận lại tại sản của mình.
Mất cộn trời là mình kẹp thay trong những bộn bà này kia, tổng trời, cơ quan cầu ăn, cầu ăn, cơ quan cầu ăn,
tổng tró, tổng tró, tổng tró này mà quán được tình tâm hơn,
mình hoàn tình đi cùng bắt trộn lượng rồi.
Mà, tôi sẽ cảm ơn tình.
Nếu như sau, quà, bỏ mẹ, dưỡi, nổ khách năng, tầy bắt trộn.
Bị trết phá thành công phía nán không chỉ thế hiệu tinh thần trù đầu, quyết liệt của lực lượng công an trong lâu trành không trưởng tụp phạm.
Mà còn có phần dưới ứng ăn đi chạp tự, mằng lại sự biện trên trên trên trên trên trên,
thơ qua phóng sự này, có quan phong ăn lệ nghiệp người dân nào bị mắt trộn tró, trong thế dân qua,
đặc biệt trên địa bàn tình gái lây, liên hệ phòng cạnh sát hình sự công an tình,
liệt phối hợp nhận giảm, sát mình và nhận lại tại sản theo quy định của phóc lực.